what's going on guys today i'm going to
break down recent evidence from the
mighty academia manga and anime
that confirms monument can duplicate one
for all and permanently pass on the
copies to other people
unlike the current overpowered version
that midoriya has these new copies would
be more like the weak version of one
floor that exists at the very beginning
in this way characters like bakugou or
todoroki can inherit these duplicates
without suffering intense blowback
and essentially they will start a new
lineage of the power that has their
respective quirks inside it
as the video continues i'll be
explaining why the public safety
commission would want this to happen
and exactly how monumental can use this
quirk to make this a reality
if you're watching i'm gonna assume you
already know what he can do but as a
reminder he can temporarily copy the
ability of anyone he physically touches
in this series so far we've seen him
replicate transformation types emitter
types
and most importantly accumulation types
and this forms the basic foundation of
the theory
accumulation type quirks operate by
stockpiling some kind of substance
with an example being how one floor
stockpile strength or how fat gum needs
to constantly eat to stock power body
fat
whenever monomer touches someone like
this it's being confirmed that he does
copy their quirk
but the one thing he can't duplicate is
the substance that they need to
accumulate
that's why when he touched erie he grew
a horn in his head since he was copying
her power
however he would have needed a lot more
time to build up whatever is required to
start rewinding
the same drawback also applied when he
replicated one for all because whereas
deku has the strength of eight previous
generations
modima only had the accumulated power of
like the previous 30 seconds
as a result his duplicate was super weak
yet when it lacked his strength it makes
up for its ability to be transferred to
other people
it's important for us to acknowledge
that the transferability of one fraud is
a core part of what it is
and you simply just can't copy it
without also acquiring that aspect of it
as well
monama's version is totally new and
independent of the one deku has
meaning he is free to do with it
whatever he wants and it is very much a
part of him until the time runs out
in the manga there is solid evidence
that implies he can transfer it
permanently
but before we get into it i want to
thank surfshot for sponsoring this video
which is a secure vpn that stands out
for all the right reasons
not only is it the only vpn i've ever
had that lets me use it on unlimited
devices
but it's also just really affordable for
a limited time you can get an
83 discount off a two-year plan plus an
additional three months on top for free
by going to search deal total quark
being from the uk there's a few anime
that's not available on any streaming
service
but thanks to this vpn i was able to
discover one of my new favorites of all
time
when it comes to death note it was
something i'd heard of in the past but
as i'm sure my fellow british people
will know
the closest thing we have available is
the live-action netflix version
with one click search like allowed me to
access so much new content including the
original death note anime
and after that i binged the entire thing
in about a week surf shark protects your
privacy as well by hiding your real ip
address
not to mention other cool features like
camouflage mode which makes it so your
internet provider can't tell you using a
vpn
if this sounds interesting then be sure
to head over to searchtalk.deal slash
shutter clock like i said
so you can get that 83 discount before
it runs out if for some unlikely reason
you don't like the service there is a 30
day money back guarantee
so it definitely doesn't hurt to try it
out okay so back to why monamer can
permanently transfer his duplicate of
one for all
let's start with the first bit of proof
usually when he copies a quirk it
expires after a period of about 10
minutes
however that exploration specifically
relates to his body in chapter 215 he
confirmed that some powers have effects
that last even after the timer runs out
with the example he used being the size
quark in that instance he had used it to
make certain objects larger
and those objects remain permanently
large even after the ability was no
longer in his possession
this was our first indication that the
effects of a kobe quirk can linger on
after monomer loses it
and i'm going to use examples to explain
why certain ones do this and others
don't
if he was to hypothetically copy all for
one and steal someone's quirk with it
that stolen power wouldn't magically
return to the person once monument's
copy of afo expires
the person who had their quirk taken
would remain quirkless as the copy of
all for one would have done something
permanent to their body
likewise if he was to copy afo and give
someone a quirk with it
i think we can all agree that they would
keep that power after the 10 minutes was
up
since their body is completely
independent of monomer in each of those
examples he would have directly affected
someone else's body with lasting
consequences
since the nature of afo allows this to
be possible this is different to
something like shinzo's brainwashing
since it requires him to constantly be
in control if monomer copies something
like that then its effects will finish
when the timer is over
but if you duplicate something like one
for all the effect of transferring it to
another person is very much a permanent
thing
remember how i said that if he gave
someone a quirk with afo it would remain
inside them even after the time was up
well that exact same principle applies
to one for all given that its
transferability is literally the same
concept
now moving over to info from recent
chapters we found out that one fall in
its current state can't be transferred
to anyone who possesses a quirk
quirkless people like deku are the
perfect candidates for this immense
power
but for people with existing abilities
it will shorten their lifespan by
various degrees
the amount their lifespan shortens by
seemingly depends on how many quads are
inside
at the time and also how much stockpile
strength it contains
hence why right now it can't be held by
an ordinary person
this is why monomers copies of once rule
are brilliant as they're restarting the
entire cycle from the very beginning
and will be able to add brand new quirks
along the way in the future when these
copies become stronger
the public safety commission can
literally create a super team of one
floor users
who are either born quirkless or
genetically modified i mentioned genetic
modification because it is canonically
possible for someone to have their body
altered to its time one for all
it's just that the only guy who can do
it right now is a mad evil scientist
anyway i've just hinted at one of the
reasons why the public safety commission
might make monomer copy deku
but let's talk about how things might
actually unfold in chapter 299 hawks
revealed the commission is effectively
shut down
after high profile members were attacked
however his wording does imply that they
will eventually return
i personally believe they will come back
because whereas the average hero stops
the crimes that are happening in the
present day
the commission was normally looking to
the future and trying to prevent things
before they went down
this is evidenced in a number of ways
including making hawks infiltrate the
league of villains
forcing leading a gun to eliminate
potential terrorists and telling kids to
participate in mandatory work studies in
preparation for what happened afterwards
even if many of their methods were both
terrible and unsuccessful
the point is that a forward-looking
institution like this is still needed to
scope out bigger threats in the future
thanks to the singularity theory we know
that quirks are becoming more powerful
and complex as time goes on
meaning that one day they will
inevitably be a villain who is even more
overpowered than afo
with all of the mixing and random
mutations going on a villain from the
first generation is not going to be the
strongest forever
and it's the responsibility of the
public safety commission to make sure
the good guys are prepared for this
that's where one floor comes in as in
the manga right now it's a bit like an
open secret
with several heroes and students being
fully aware of what it is
the general population also knows
midoriya has multiple abilities
not to mention there were people outside
his hospital demanding to know what one
floor is after the war arc was over
this situation implies it might become
public in the not-too-distant future
and if that happens the commission will
react in a big way they obviously
wouldn't want a power like this to ever
disappear
and depending on how much they know the
first thing they do is look into the
quark registry for quercus individuals
in japan by the commission keeping tabs
on these people and their possibly
quirkless children over the years
it's a great way of having a group to
select from a midoriya one day decides
to retire
currently 20 of the global population
don't have a quirk which is over a
billion people
and although that number will decrease
it still means there should be thousands
if not millions of quirkle's japanese
citizens when the time comes
not all of them are going to be young
people that aspire to be heroes but if
the commission continuously monitors the
quirk registry
they're guaranteed to find some suitable
candidates who could be deku's successor
the second thing they'd want to do is
create backup versions of one for all in
case midoriya was either killed before
he could pass it on
and moname is the person to make that
happen by repeatedly copying deku and
then passing the weak copy to other
heroes
there will be countless backups that
will one day become as powerful as
midoriya himself
in 50 years time you could theoretically
have a version of one floor that has
half hot half cold inside it
and other versions that have dark shadow
explosion or whatever else it may be
these duplicates would also possibly
have copy inside them as well
but i am a bit unsure about that one so
let me know in the comments
do you think these copies would have
copy inside now i know that some of you
might be wondering if the heroes would
be reducing their lifespans by having
one for all
but we've seen that the negative effects
take a certain amount of time to kick in
especially depending on how powerful or
weak it might be if shinomori can
survive
18 years after inheriting the strength
of three previous users and two extra
quirks on top of that
then you estimate someone like bakugou
should be able to take this blank one
for all
and have it for about 10 years with no
lasting consequences
i'll reiterate again that these copies
would have no power and also maybe at
most one extra quirk
so yeah i reckon someone like bakago
could have it for that period of time
and then yeah just pass it on to the
next person an example might be that
todoroki could have a copy for five
years before passing it on to tenure for
two years
and when the copy becomes too powerful
for ordinary people the commission could
make them pass it on to one of the
quirks candidates they've been training
in this way the hero side would be
guaranteed to have several multiple
quirk users in the future which will
help fight against the possible rise and
stronger villains
it will also safeguard society by making
sure deku's power doesn't die out
and for once it also means that people
without quirks will be highly valued
while it is true that one day there will
be virtually zero quirkle's people
like i said earlier modifying someone's
body to withstand one for all is already
possible in this universe so it's just a
question of turning that idea into a
more humane method
anyway guys be sure to let me know what
you think of the duplication theory down
below and don't forget to hit that sub
button as it's my personal goal to get
400k by the end of the year
there's also the 83 surfshot discount
that i mentioned earlier
and if you want to get it then go to
search deals total quirk
until the next one peace out